what's going on reject nation Cregg
outta here and I'm John so we're gonna
watch the comic-con trailer for the lego
ninjago movie oh boy came out a lot
earlier today we're just finally getting
around to it I remember when comments
were coming out on the first reaction I
did with Stacy Howard people were like
oh this isn't the Ninjago I wanted
because I think there's like a show that
okay learn and are a comedy movie we're
getting so some people have been a
little upset by it I thought the first
show was really funny it's cool to see
the LCU expanding amen anything like
this is going to go through that I think
it'll ease now a data we're like we find
in tones it works really well the first
movie and then we're going to do that
tone for a while so people start to get
kind of tired of that and want some more
diversity into then I imagine something
more resembling that show as possible
down the line as soon as people start
going hey we don't only want this one
kind of rider hey mom
Jaka barrows
doggone so when you guys got together
was dead always an evil period I got so
many plans in ambition he said he wanted
to conquer all for that lady over the
bigger seat go ahead never mad Garmadon
I would never had you to need Janos in
what you fight and when to shut it
[Music]
the Lloyd that's right boys dad
baby it's okay boy nobody turns the
first thing yeah but I feel like there's
more going on that I need to know to
understand your future you must go back
to your ninja roots your death ninja -
Wow how paranoid you hear that we
don'twe community what
[Music]
why are you ready to risk your life
[Music]
us Olivia mine again
[Music]
let's go canoeing along good boy okay
yeah I think I think was my
understanding how bad is it
oh I'd say it's about a seven point or
[Music]
so it seems like as I saw the Lego
Batman movie once but it's in my big
spirit away a little bit from Lego jokes
yeah and here there seems to be more
Lego jokes again oh yeah any ripped-off
know genitalia yes yeah this is very
much inside the Lego world like Ninjago
is a creation of Lego yeah exactly and
you get that sense in this in this
trailer for sure yeah that was a really
fun trailer who looks like a really
funny movie me it's like everything I
liked about the lego movie in the Lego
Batman movie the animation looks superb
that comedy looks really on par has a
wide cast of voice actors here
everything about it seems really funny
of the cat thing was really weird to me
was that like a riff on like monsters
attacking the city kind of thing oh yeah
and that's what would be in a lego world
you know if you have this like if you
think back to the lego movie that whole
thing where it's just like a city on a
table yeah I'm sure the cow jump up on
there so as one of the things that like
half of my mind wishes that could have
been a surprise to this year because I
think that would've been really funny
but the other half I just think that's a
hilarious idea you know the alive
actually cat messing up the city feel
like Will Ferrell and his son are the
Santos of this universe yeah it is shape
everything that everyday all the stories
have a really good heart and message in
them and yeah and this one's exploring
you know the father and son territory
and even though my dad is bad I want to
be able to understand him in some
capacity or help them in some way
they're sweet and funny and imaginative
and everything has you know a sense of
heart about any Lego at least in terms
of the lego movie Lego Batman movie and
what I've seen of this I feel like they
have a nice tonus that was totally sorry
I can see why you would want it to
change and shift over time but right now
you know
they're doing a solid job of it I think
they should go darker darker yet all of
our characters have a five o'clock
shadow longer hair that's the key and
Jackie Chan's in the Jackie Chan man
only Asian voice actor in the lego
ninjago movie is Olivia money hey Olivia
Munn's Asian - she's hot she's
attractive yes she's very hot she's
quite attractive remember her and x-men
apocalypse I don't remember what she did
but I remember what she wore remember
her on on g4 TV she's really gone from
like hosted personality just full-out
extras I mean good for her soul Tyrone
Magnus who can I row well guys thanks
for tuning in
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell - John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram check out our
exclusive person wars over at
patreon.com slash the real rejects
haunted rollin now we're waiting for the
TV panels of flash and the marble panel
my favorite shows flash Nate oh god I've
got see those trailers man got to see
what's happening in seasons 4 & 6
respected